[Musique]
si je vous dis caramel à la fleur de sel
vous pensez quoi ça évoque quoi ya la
télé en odorama ce n'est pas pour tout
de suite et c'est bien dommage car il
flotte dans l'air des effluves disons
enivrante le caramel c'est du site brûlé
et quand on se sent on est tout de suite
appelé par cette odeur de caramel et
personnes qui reste insensible à ça
comme ladders barbecue si on est attiré
vers ça
nous sommes fous du caramel et depuis
longtemps on retrouve d'ailleurs dans
tout bon livre de référence des recettes
de sauce au caramel et on mange et
surtout le temps qu'on remettait ça sur
le gâteau c'est la sauce du dessin on
faisait un beigne avec une sauce au
caramel une tarte une sauce au caramel
mais ce n'est pas du vrai caramel à
tartiner levrette carmel à tartiner ces
français ce sont aussi des français qui
les premiers ont introduit du sel dans
leurs caramel il ya eu une taxe à très
très très longtemps des centaines
d'années y avait une taxe sur la sur le
sel mais en bretagne la bretagne avaient
été protégés de ça et puis avait pas eu
de taxes l'a donc eux ils faisaient
leurs bars à lait y mettait du sel par
tous ses pôles c'est peut-être le marché
noir
déjà le caramel et il mettait le bars à
lait le sel est un exhausteur de goût et
le sucre et le sel quand il se rend
compte c'est une vraie merveille en c1
est donc là bien évidemment ça a exalté
le goût du caramel de
de la canalisation et les variations
pour émoustiller nos papilles sont
maintenant à l'infini on peut mettre les
épices on pourrait mettre du sésame
on peut mettre des épiceries 40 prenait
toutes sortes de choses avec le caramel
tout va bien avec le caramel et vous
quand vous faites un caramel c'est quoi
votre secret pour être patient le sucre
il faut le laisser monter doucement il
vient pas rapidement breux il faut y
aller doucement et ça ça nous ça importe
cette belle texture qui va rester dans
nos peaux après textures délicates fine
et surtout souple ce qu'on veut c'est
après pouvoir en maître sur sa crème
placé en maître sur ces deux le matin
dans son bain bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que je fasse pour réussir mon père
américain
d'abord on va faire chauffer la crème et
le beurre ensemble un le beurre va
fondre dans la crème
pendant ce temps là dans notre casserole
on a notre glucose avec le sud on attend
que ça monte à 160 comme vous faites la
caramélisation n'y a pas de liquide
c'est que le sucre et le gras et le
sucré le glucose on ajoute un petit peu
d'eau mais pas beaucoup
et une fois qu'on a le bon degré là il
faut opérer vais te tuer on transfère
entre notre caramel os x comme ça c'est
une claque les froides
c'est à cette étape qu'il faut ajouter
le beurre fondu avec la crème il faut
fouetter mais il faut y aller doucement
parce que ça va gonfler ça va monter le
sucre a tendance à vouloir résister à la
crème mais bon d'accord c'est à ce
moment là vous ajoutez le sel non une
grosse cuillère à soupe pour vos impôts
donc il ne faut pas en être encore il
faut penser qu'on est parti à la base
avec du beurre salé déjà et on ampute
quand c'est chaud ça brûle faut faire
attention au chien mais jamais jamais
faire ça avec des enfants on travaille
avec des linges pour tenir les po puis
on les retourne à l'envers comme on fait
pour les confitures parce que comme ça
nous on s'aime l'epo pas besoin de faire
ça à la maison si vous faites 10 po de
caramel puis vous le mettez dans votre
frigo vous allez tous les manger dans
semaine
la couleur on parle du caramel quand il
est très très clair c'est un caramel cas
pas été assez car mehdi ou qui a été
fait avec la cassonade et quand il est
très très foncé il a été trop grillé au
départ cela il va avoir des petits goût
de brûlé sous peu intéressants beaucoup
font leur caramel à la maison avec les
cas ça y est on sait de la sauce mais
beaucoup font les caramels dans les pots
cassés d'adosser et cvc pas heureux
comme comme texture ça donne toujours
une texture un peu grossière un peu
granuleuse s'est fortement intéressant
on appâte heure pineau batch comment
dire en france n va
[Musique]